we're talking about moral and political
principles here we're talking about
first principles uh what comprises the
good life that's where the real
disagreement wait I guess I'm not seeing
that isn't um fewer children dying a
moral principle that is we ought to have
fewer children dying it's good to have
fewer people dying it's evil to let kids
die if you could prevent
[Music]
it so Johnny are you confident that
things aren't going to slip backwards
again or do you see new myths forming to
replace the old ones well it's not so
much myths I again I think that reason
can lead individuals to come up with
smart
views that the world Works in one way
and lead other individuals to come up
with smart views that the world Works in
other ways in international relations
the world I operate in I have a
particular theory of realism I argue
that realism best explains how the world
Works Steve is a very smart guy and he
uses his critical faculties to think
about how the world works and he comes
up with a fundamentally different view
of international politics than I do it's
what I would call a liberal View and
that is my basic point that smart
individuals right can use their critical
faculty to come up with different views
and when you have different views how do
you have progress the fact that Steve
and I disagree about International
progress about international relations
makes me wonder whether it makes sense
to talk about us achieving progress in
understanding how the world
works if we take say the history of
science as our guide we find that at any
given time there are controversies there
are people who you yell at each other
there people hate each other's guts
there are people who uh each thinks the
other one is stupid um but you know
sometimes they enough years pass enough
empirical tests are done enough
arguments are aired and we find that one
of them was right one of them was wrong
uh rewind the clock 80 years and
scientists disagreed over whether
heredity was um uh carried in in protein
or DNA and the DNA DNA guys won and the
protein guys lost uh it may be that even
in the realm of international relations
if John and I say and you know John and
his various colleagues and various
colleagues even tried to let's say we we
had an adversarial collaboration and we
tried to make concrete predictions about
what would happen in the next you know
year five years 10 years 15 years time
passes and maybe one of us is wrong one
of them is right and in fact in even in
the areas in which retrospectively we
made predictions I think there are some
cases in which each of us has um
probably made predictions that are
embarrassed by the the course of events
uh did Germany try to acquire nuclear
weapons uh
was did did uh the era of one nation
state invading another to try to acquire
Territory go into OB bance uh you know I
think each of us uh did did the uh rate
of War increase or decrease after the uh
fall of the uh the transition from
bipolarity to unipolarity probably if we
rewound the clock U probably both of us
would have some embarrassments and some
successes but but uh
uh done proactively uh maybe our
descendants in 25 years will say oh
liberalism is a good idea but it was
falsified or vice versa maybe realism
seemed like a good idea at the time but
historical events have shown it to be
wrong so at any given time of course
there will be controversy over the
controversial issues but it doesn't mean
that controversies are are never
resolved I I think Steve when you're
talking about the moral and political
realm as opposed to let's say the
medical realm right in the moral and
political realm it is almost impossible
to reach meaningful consensus uh on a
widespread scale uh there's always going
to be significant disagreement this is
my basic point that how how about the um
desirability of a Marxist leninist uh
command and control economy and
political system um I I think there's I
there's not you know espe including in
Academia there's not complete consensus
but I think that reble people would say
yeah we tried that experiment didn't
work I think there's no question that
ideas come and go right and I I think
that the example of what's happened with
Marxism is basically correct it had its
Heyday and uh it's uh no longer a very
influential ideology but the point is
it's not that the new ideologies that
have appeared and the old ideologies
that have hung on uh have fought with
each other and we've had some sort of
dialectical process that has led to a
consensus and my argument is you need a
consensus um to uh uh to get progress
and what we're talking about here the
dependent variable so to speak is moral
and political progress let's pick back
up with this um idea of the individual
for example um the individual uh John um
Steve's individual is not this isolated
um entity they are a multisociety
and their social belonging they're
members of many different sorts of
groups and that's in some sense what is
individual about them it's just that no
one predominates there are distinctions
and divisions even within Nations
nations are not unified Concepts what do
you think to that look I think when you
think about human nature Sophie you have
to ask yourself a basic question do you
think that we are first and foremost
individuals who form social contracts
this is what liberalism is all about or
do you think that we are first and
foremost social individuals who carve
out room for our
individualism almost all Enlightenment
thinkers and I think this is true of
Steve start with the individual the
focus is on the individual uh and it's
individual reason that really matters my
argument is that we are first and
foremost social animals we're born and
socialized into tribes what we now call
Nations and folks like Steve believe
that those tribes get in the way of
rational thinking and uh they get in the
way of coming to some sort of consensus
which equals progress and this is
quoting from Steve he says political
tribalism is the most Insidious form of
irrationality today political tribalism
which you acquain with the nation in
your work I'm arguing that there is some
truth in that that nationalism identity
with a nation the fact that we live in a
world of nation states makes it
difficult to reach progress but if you
do believe that we are social animals
that causes all sorts of problems for
Steve's argument yeah one of the
challenges of the Enlightenment is how
do you have larg scale social groupings
like Nations without uh coercion of
forcing people to to um sacrifice their
interests for a majority or even the
most powerful so uh the um you know and
that's why we have liberal democracy
that's why we have freedom of speech uh
that's why Nations have uh decreasingly
identified themselves with some single
religion or ethnic group and have uh H
have become defined admittedly
retrospectively by something closer to a
social contract now it's not
historically true that people sat down
together and they hashed out the details
for for a country but in terms of
rationalizing what are the defensible
arrangements for a country yeah I don't
think United States I think it's really
good the United States is not a
Christian Nation I think it's not a it's
good that it doesn't Define itself as a
white Nation or even an Anglo nation
that and the other nations that people
want to live in are nations that are
Multicultural that uh accept difference
that recognize rights of individuals
among the rights of individuals are to
affiliate voluntarily with groups like
religions or clubs or uh whatever they
want but to have the violence that is
monopolized by a state identified with a
particular ethnic group I I would argue
is a terrible idea because you're never
going to have only the members of One
bloodline of one Kindred of one ethnic
group of one religion uh sharing a
territory ter people move around they
have feet every territory has people
from multiple backgrounds multiple
tribes multiple cultures uh it's really
a bad idea if the wielder of the
enormous Force called a government
serves the interests of only one uh one
bloodline I think that's a uh that is an
ancient idea I think we're we naturally
regress to it I do you know I do believe
in human nature I of all people I wrote
a book called in defense of human nature
called the blank slate but I do think
that there's some features of human
nature like like greed like lust like
exploitation like sadism like Revenge
that we ought to develop institutions to
control and tribalism being one of them
now why do I think the tribalism leads
to irrationality well I'll be I'll be
very concrete you present the same
policy prescription here's a way to do
healthc care you say this came from the
uh the the American Democratic party the
Democrats favorite the Republicans
oppose it they take the exact same
policy you say oh this came from the
America the Republican party now the rep
Republicans favor the democ Democrats
oppose it now that's irrational likewise
you give people math problems uh results
of a study if it favors a liberal policy
prescription the uh liberals will
Overlook mathematical errors and vice
versa and um conversely if it's a it
supports a conservative position if you
give people a logical syllogism and it's
consistent with a left-wing position the
the leftists will think it's logically
impeccable the right the right-wingers
will disagree and conversely if the
syllogism leads to a different
conclusion so tribalism patently leads
to irrationality classically uh defined
that is making math errors and logic
errors and and logical
inconsistencies and I think it's an
incoherent basis for a modern nation
state because nations are all
heterogeneous look I'm happy that I live
in a country that is not a Christian
country and I'm happy to live in a
multiculture cultural country I do not
want to live in a white country period
okay so you and I agree on that but the
point I would make to you Steve is that
there are a lot of our fellow Americans
who disagree with you and me on that and
furthermore once you go outside the
boundaries of the United States as you
will know there are lots of countries
who think that you know
multi-ethnic societies is a bad thing
and they regret that they have X's or
y's living inside their borders and
they'd like to push them out or suppress
them or so forth and so on there's not a
lot of Harmony in those multiethnic
States and again that is what underpins
my argument that we have not made a lot
of progress over time uh yeah well
there's the part of the argument I'm
making is normative that is it is true
that there are a lot of societies that
try to be um monolithic ethnostates um
you know I argue that that's many of us
would argue that that's uh not viable
that they will be um torn by Strife
because they will have significant
minorities and that it's bad to expel
them it's bad to to repress them it's
bad to deny them rights so there's that
normative argument then there's the
argument of you know kind of are those
of us who believe this you know are we
winning uh and it's certainly not true
that we have convinced the entire world
but the there's an a separate question
of what has been the Trend that is do
you are do you have more societies that
uh that recognize minority rights that
say extend the franchise to every
religion in every ethnic group do you
have more societies that criminalize a
religion it's it's not um unanimous it
hasn't swept over the entire Globe but I
think in fact that has been the the the
trend that is the there are more if you
I have one graph in better angels of our
nature it hasn't been updated in the
last 15 years or so but over a span of
about 60 years if you plot the number of
nations that have various kinds ofate or
Jim Crow like um discrimination laws on
the books uh and the proportion that
have various the opposite various kind
of affirmative action policies on their
books the the curves AC crossed so more
countries today actually put a thumb on
the scale in favor of their minorities
than uh legally oppress them now it's
still not 100% 0%
and uh maybe it shouldn't be but
certainly but but the the empirical fact
of how many people are convinced that
this is the way a society ought to be
run is also separate from how ought a
society to be run can we talk about
liberalism um in the sense that actually
it's the political idea the political
concept that's best of that does best at
handling the sort of differences that
we're that we're talking about um and
that actually that's why it's so it's so
successful John what do you think about
that I I agree completely with that I I
think that liberalism is predicated on
the assumption that individuals cannot
agree about first principles they cannot
agree about questions of the good life
and sometimes those disagreements are so
intense that people kill each other so
liberalism deals with that fundamental
set of problems
right by
creating Civil Society by giving people
room to live life the way they see fit
liberalism also privileges individual
rights it says that you sopie have the
right to live this way I John have the
right to live this way and we can live
life the way we see fit in Civil Society
furthermore liberalism preaches
tolerance and the reason that liberalism
preach reaches tolerance is because
again people can't agree on first
principles so if you and Steve have
fundamentally different views on
religion and there's a danger that one
of you will kill the other because of
that disagreement what you want to do is
inculcate you with tolerance teach you
to tolerate each other's different views
and then finally liberalism privileges
the creation of a state to make sure
that no single person is in a position
to kill another person but that's what
liberalism is all about it's all about
dealing with the fact that there is no
consensus there is no consensus on
political and moral questions of the
first order so is progress Steve really
when it comes down to it actually just
acknowledging that no consensus is
really possible we just have to learn to
live and manage these differences as
best we can is that actually an
alternative account of progress well you
could that argument but I my point is
just quickly Steve I think that's not
Steve's definition of
progress yeah I think that it's it's a
component that but it's not the
definition of progress I would Define
progress as uh enhancements in human
flourishing and I gave a list of uh you
know health safety sub sustenance um the
things that people want for themselves
basically when when given a choice but
the but yes disagree the fact of
disagreement stemming from the
undeniable fact that humans um are
different both individually and
culturally but nonetheless have to come
to working Arrangements despite that
disagreement the fact that despite the
disagreement some uh some factual
opinions are better than others we don't
know them a priori because we're not uh
the truth has not been vouch safed to us
from from from some deity it hasn't been
stated in scriptures we got to blunder
along and discover what the truth is um
likewise we've got to experiment blunder
uh to uh to find the best uh
arrangements for living together and
some of them work better than others in
terms of the criteria of enhancing human
flourishing um people will disagree at
any given time but I think it's an
exaggeration to say that no one
disagrees with agrees with anyone else
uh on any first principle if you look at
the uh un sustainable development goals
every country 193 countries agreed on
which way the world ought to go that is
poverty should be reduced safety should
be increased access to clean water
should be uh increased child death
should be decreased infectious disease
should be decreased there's a awful lot
of agreement and then we can reframe
other arguments as what will get us to
the state that uh many of us agree on
now again not everyone there are some
people who have Messianic visions that
the world is not going to be a great
place till everyone obeys all of God's
Commandments and if if if kids die some
it doesn't matter one way or another but
to the extent that people do agree that
baby's dying is is bad and you know by
and large they do then we can that
changes the argument from disagreements
over first principles to disagreements
over means to the end and even then if
you look at the sustainable development
goals there's an awful lot of agreement
over over things that the world's
Nations should get together and do I
just don't think Steve there's any
disagreement on issues of safety health
and Su sustenance that's not the issue
we're talking about moral and political
principles here we're talking at first
principles uh what comprises the good
life that's where the real
disagreement I guess I'm not seeing that
isn't um fewer children dying a moral
principle that is we ought to have fewer
children dying it's good to have fewer
people dying it's evil to let kids die
if you can prevent it no I think that's
so obvious is to not even be interesting
I mean well but wait a second but then
those are first principles that everyone
agrees on you didn't need the
enlightenment to produce that right the
argument here is The Enlightenment and
using our critical faculties Chang
things we were finally able to make
moral and political progress I think
from time immemorial people have
understood that you know young children
dying is a bad thing and what we should
do is try and keep them alive for as
long as possible well but there was I
mean we did have things like you know
slavery and human sacrifice and uh
genocide of other peoples and we had um
you know praying to famine as opposed to
developing vigorous hybrids and and
artificial fertilizers and crop rotation
so the means to attend uh to to attain
those different as well but even the
idea of universal human flourishing that
isn't so obvious uh you one could you
you go back into uh a lot of religious
codes and the idea that every last
member of homo sapiens ought to flourish
you know off isn't there if we have if
we find a lot of these Concepts
problematic are there any sort of really
viable alternative or actually are we
kind of stuck with trying to to make you
know the the sort of Enlightenment
values as we've been talking about them
very broadly um are we stuck with trying
to make them work or are there other
Alternatives
well the first Enlightenment value uh is
unfettered reason unfettered reason is
put up on pedestal I believe that
unfettered reason should be put up on a
pedestal and I would think that all
three of us as academics would agree
with that I think the dispute between me
and Steve has more to do with what
unfettered reason leads to when it comes
to important moral and political
questions but I'm in favor of that
second sort of principal value of the
Enlightenment is the focus on the
individual and I do like individualism
and again as academics individualism
really matters
as we all know so I'm not against
individualism but my basic Point uh as
I've emphasized here is that we are all
social animals and that we have to carve
out space for our individualism the fact
that you Sophie live in Britain and
Steve and I live in the United States
has an influence on how we think about
the world and in my opinion that makes
it more difficult to reach some sort of
consensus to reach some sort of Truth on
important political and social values so
I'm um I'm of a mixed mind about the
individualism uh but uh I do like
individualism but you have to understand
that again we're social animals first
and for foremost and then with regard to
IR which was my third point before uh I
think that we live in a fundamentally
competitive world uh States compete with
each other in nasty ways often and
sometimes they even fight Wars uh and
that situ situation has not changed
since the beginning of time and it's not
going to change in the future and I
don't think we've made any progress
there although Steve has a particular
argument that I haven't addressed which
I'll leave aside for the
moment well you know the more you try to
formulate alternatives to uh
Enlightenment ideals the better they
look because what are the Alternatives
if you start to argue against reason
well why should we take that seriously
if it's either it's reasonable in which
case you find on to reason or it's not
reasonable in which case there's no
reason to to go along with them likewise
if you're really against individualism
are you okay with your parents arranging
a marriage for you are you okay with
being forced to go to church every
Sunday uh are you forced to are you okay
with being forced to do anything uh for
the coherence of the the group not
expressing your opinion because it might
so disagreement and dissent and that
would be you know uncomfortable uh it's
very hard to argue for an alternative to
to uh
individualism uh as long as
individualism includes the people's
preference to belong to various social
collectives international relations
probably we should have a whole other
discussion of that because I do think
things have changed but that's uh maybe
John and I will agree to disagree on
that um but the again I would
distinguish the
normative uh issue of what ought we to
persuade one another of to argue for to
Advocate from the uh kind of
triumphalist argument that uh we've won
everyone agrees with me no everyone
doesn't agree with me you know I think
they ought to I don't think they ever I
don't think we'll ever reach the point
where everyone will and I wouldn't want
to you know have the the the dictatorial
power to force people to uh but I do
think the trend has been in that
direction as it happens now those are
separate it could be there are ideals
that would be good if more and more
people adopt and they're immune to
reason and they do the wrong thing um
those are two separate arguments but I
would argue the enlightenment ideals a
are what we ought to strive for and B
they haven't triumphed but that's the
direction that uh that we've been going
I think Steve that there is a large
element of triumphalism in your book and
in fact when I read it carefully I
couldn't help but think about Frank
fukiyama as very famous article the end
of History which was published in
1989 because Frank's argument is that
we're making progress that in fact we
defeated fascism in the first half of
the 20th century communism in the second
half of the 20th century and the future
is liberalism in other words liberal
democracies like the United States have
the wind at our back and what we're
going to get over time is more and more
liberal democracy and this is progress
and once you have this kind of progress
you don't have fundamental disagreement
on moral and political issues and in
fact given that the country uh that all
the countries of the world will be
liberal democracies there's not going to
be much political disagreement out there
and you remember Frank's big argument at
the end of his famous article was that
the biggest problem we would face going
forward was boredom and the reason we
would face boredom is there would be no
more politics right there would be no
more fights my argument is because of
the limits of reason the limits of
unfettered Reason what you get are
really big fights where people are
willing to kill each other and that's
what makes politics to use Barack Obama
and Bill Clinton's phrase a contact
sport and once politics which is a
contact sport is at play right you're
not going to make a lot of progress and
in fact you're going to need a state to
keep everybody under
control yes and of course the end uh the
end of History was deliberately
ambiguous in the two ways that I
mentioned between that is uh you could
read it as the goal the D the uh uh
direction that political systems uh are
are aiming at or ought to aim at and the
uh factual claim that in fact uh we've
got there that history in terms of say
great conflicts has ended I read him as
arguing more for the former than than
the latter and of course he wrote it
before the Berlin Wall fell before the
Cold War ended if you're just going to
tally up the number of liberal
democracies he had a point and that they
certainly increased subsequent to uh
writing it now that process has stalled
has even gone a bit backwards and you
know maybe you and I could have a
friendly bed over where whether in we
won't be alive probably in 25 years to
settle the bet but whether there'll be
more liberal democracies or more
autocracies well and on that note um
Steve John thank you that was absolutely
fantastic I'm sure everyone watching
will join me to um to thank you very
much for such an interesting
discussion